Ah, threading.
So powerful that you can
fold genomes with it,
but so difficult
that it can drive
the average programmer insane.
My name is Cole
McCandless, and as far
as Android development
is concerned,
threading is one of the most
important and most confusing
things that you can
deal with, which
means if you want to write
the fastest app possible,
you've gotta take a minute and
understand the subtle art that
is multithreaded programming.
Remember that in the vast
world of Android functions
there's a whole boatload of
operations that only execute
on the main thread--
system events, input
events, application callback
services, and even alarms.
And for the most part,
any code that you write
executes inside one of these
operations, which means it also
runs on the main thread.
Now, if you recall, work that
executes on the main thread
gets there after being pulled
from the front of a work queue,
so blocks of work
are done in order,
and the next block of
work isn't processed
until the current
one is completed,
which means if there is a large
chunk of work between an input
event and its
callback, then the user
will have to wait longer
than expected to see results.
And don't forget that
the main thread is also
where most of the
screen rendering occurs.
While an animation or
screen update is occurring,
the system will try to
draw the screen every 16
milliseconds or so to achieve
smooth 60 frames per second.
The problem is that
this is happening
while the thread is also
responding to app input events.
So if your app is in the
middle of an animation
and some random work packet
takes longer than expected,
you'll miss your chance
to render that next frame
within the 16
millisecond window,
and that frame will be delayed.
This is what we call a dropped
frame, and when this happens,
users start to notice.
The direct solution
here is to move anything
that might upset the
16 millisecond window
over somewhere else, like
to a different thread.
This way it won't be contesting
with the UI thread for work
to be done, and
won't be interrupting
the drawing of the screen, which
is the whole point of threading
on Android in a nutshell.
So the question at hand,
what's the best way
to offload this work, and how
do you choose what types of work
to offload?
Thankfully, the
Android framework
has provided a
handful of classes
to help make this a
bit easier for you.
For example, the
AsyncTask class is
ideal for helping you get
work on and off the UI
thread the right way.
HandlerThreads
are great when you
need a dedicated thread
for callbacks to land on.
ThreadPools work best when
you can break your work up
into really small
packets, and then
toss them to a bunch of
threads, and IntentServices
are really ideal for
background tasks,
or when you need to get
intent work off the UI thread.
And like everything else, there
is not a silver bullet here,
but knowing which
primitive is best
for what situation can save
you a lot of headaches.
But note that having all
those fancy helper classes
doesn't hide the
big problem, memory.
See, threading and memory
have never really played well,
and on the Android
platform it's no different.
For example, if you declare
one of those fancy threading
primitives inside
of an activity,
it now contains an
implicit reference
to the outer activity,
which can cause a memory
leak if the activity
is destroyed,
but the threaded
work is still alive.
Or, what happens when the
user rotates the device,
destroying an
activity that spawned
a bunch of threaded work?
I mean, chances are
that those work packets
would have references
back to various UI objects
that don't really exist anymore.
And the truth is that
the Android platform
is flooded with threads.
If you need a reminder of
that, grab a Systrace capture
and check out all
the cool stuff that's
going on underneath the hood
that you never really knew
about.
See, at the end of
the day, threading
is critical to ensure
high performance
of your android app, but
there's lots of other problems
that you have to worry
about that as well, which
is why you should check out the
rest of the Android Performance
Patterns videos.
And also, don't forget to join
our Google+ community so that
you can ask questions when
you run into problems.
So keep calm, profile your
code, and always remember,
perf matters.
[MUSIC]